[Musik]
sebastian buck angebliches fitness brot
junge junge das gesund aus
alles nur kohlenhydrate zu sparen lege
packt aus und zeigt wie gesund die
eiweiß brote wirklich sind
bei weißbrot der neue fitness mythos 82
schreiben gegessen morgens rank und
schlank das funktionieren würde fände
ich das nur noch füttern die idee ohne
kohlenhydrate muss der körper die
energie aus den fettreserven ziehen
und wenn abends keine kohlenhydrate mehr
aufgenommen werden dann sollen die
fettpolster sogar im schlaf abschmelzen
das eiweiß soll außerdem den
muskelaufbau begünstigen
etwas mehl steckt in allen eiweiß broten
allerdings nur um die zehn prozent
80 prozent sind sonst standard als
ersatz gibt es dafür zutaten wie erbsen
ackerbohnen und kleie ist das dann
überhaupt noch ein brot das
sieht aus wie der spiels war bei mir in
der küche ob das schmeckt eine gute
scheibe aus der mitte
was schon mal auffällt
durch einen hohen eiweißgehalt ist es
sehr feucht
mache ein bisschen dicker butter
aufgebote haben wir keine kohlenhydrate
[Musik]
da kann man essen
aber schön ist das nicht
ja dieses abgepackte typen brot für dich
persönlich nicht ganz so lecker aber
vielleicht schmeckt das ja frisch aus
dem ofen
für den fairen geschmacks vergleich
backt sebastian erst einmal ein ganz
normales brot
mail
hefe
bisschen salz haben war kein griff im
teig kurz einmal durchführen
wasser dazugeben
[Musik]
ist ja wirklich kinderleicht und
fertig ist der heutigen tag
weizenmehl ist ein echter alleskönner
es gibt im brot struktur form und
geschmack damit bei weißbrot auch fast
ohne mehl zusammenhält sind einige
tricks nötig jetzt passen sie mal auf
wieviel zutaten benötigt werden um so
ein neues blut herzustellen
[Musik]
hier
vollkornmehl ein bisschen kleiner als
wein zum vollkornmehl normales
weizenmehl weizeneiweiß
ackerbohnen erbsen ein bisschen
sauerteig hilfe natürlich auch ein
bisschen salz sesam einsam und sammlung
gerne
für ein industrielles bei weißbrot sind
16 zutaten nötig klassisches brot
braucht gerade mal 4
[Musik]
wo also viele zutaten wahnsinn
die extraportion eiweiß malt sich
sebastian erstmal aus erbsen
weil
die grate macht schlank
aus ackerbohnen mehl hefe und sauerteig
entsteht der grund teig auch die kerne
und samen gibt sebastian schon dazu und
jetzt wie band normal im brotteig
erstmal die trockenen zutaten mischen
kleiner tipp am rande immer etwas
trockene mission bevor die flüssigen
oder die feuchten komponenten hinzu
kommen so haben sie eine bessere
verteilung an sich und das wird einfach
besser
[Musik]
der mischung fehlt noch die bindung die
liefert bei klassischem brot das mehl
ohne weizen und ohne die typischen
eigenschaften geht es natürlich gar
nicht wir brauchen wir am meisten von ja
weizeneiweiß
die lebensmittelindustrie setzt bei der
herstellung von eiweiß brot vollauf
weizeneiweiß besser bekannt als beauty
das wird aus weizen gewonnen damit ist
gluten aus mehl die wichtigste zutat um
ein weißbrot herzustellen
[Musik]
in großen industrieanlagen wird weizen
in seine bestandteile zerlegt zunächst
werden die körner gesäubert und dann in
13 vollautomatischen mühlen von grob bis
ganz fein vermahlen
die ballaststoffe im korn werden dabei
aussortiert wasser und kochsalzlösung
lösen die stärke aus dem feinen mail
sämtliche kohlenhydrate landen dadurch
in dieser milchigen brühe
übrig bleibt eine gummiartige masse blut
ihn
getrocknet und zu pulver vermahlen ist
es der ideale helfer im reichstag
weizenkleie und gluten sorgen dafür dass
der teig zusammenhält und sich überhaupt
zu einem brot backen lässt
junge junge sieht das gesund aus
alles nur um kohlenhydrate zu sparen
fünf minuten später ist der teig fertig
in der konsistenz er fest
[Musik]
du hast
immer hier so klassischer brotteig
also hiermit können sie fensterscheiben
ein schmeißen
die vielen körner und samen machen den
teig schwer und kompakt
so der backstein ziegel ist so ein
fertig machen wir ein bisschen hübsch
oder sehr gesund sein
bei 180 grad kommt das brot in den
vorgeheizten ofen rein damit
abwarten und genießen und ganz wichtig
bloß keine kohlenhydrate
90 minuten später ist das brot fertig
sehr gut aus
und jetzt muss ich probieren aber
kommen was soll's wir
tun ja alles für den ruhm
[Musik]
manchmal sagen
das ist meine
vision sie was für vorteile
weissbrodt kann man richtig deftig
belegen sind ja auch keine kohlenhydrate
auf die schlanke linie
wie gesund sind nun die eiweiß brote
kann man mit dieser kohlenhydratarmen
diät wirklich kinderleicht abnehmen
[Musik]
er mögliche gesundheitliche vorteile von
kohlenhydratarmen diäten stichwort low
carb der wird schon relativ lange
untersucht man sieht in diesen studien
dass man mit einer hohen raab am diät
verglichen mit einer fettarme diät etwas
mehr an gewicht verliert zumindestens im
mittelfristigen zeitrahmen nach einem
jahr oder länger sieht man diese
unterschiede nicht mehr wie genau sich
das auf den menschlichen stoffwechsel
auswirkt ob das für jeden menschen gilt
und ob das eben nur für die
kohlenhydrate gilt oder auch für andere
nährstoffe das überhaupt nicht
ausreichend geklärt es gibt also keinen
grund gezielt auf kohlenhydrate am abend
zu verzichten der aufwand für ein
weißbrot ist groß und gehen lassen sich
die hersteller bezahlen unter vier euro
pro kilo haben wir im supermarkt nichts
gefunden
das ist deutlich mehr als der preis für
ein frisches brot beim bäcker
[Musik]
wenn euch das video gefallen hat und
gesagt ich will noch mehr vom zdf besser
esser sehen dann einfach hier klicken da
gibt es mehr videos von uns und wenn wir
uns abonniert genau hier würde ich mich
richtig freuen